ما راينا على الشاشه من صور لما يبدو انها
ضربه شديده على غزه
هذا صحيح هي ثلاث غارات وليست واحده
نفذتها الطائرات الحربيه الاسرائيليه في
محافظات شمال قطاع غزه وبالتحديد في منطقه
جباليا وتخوم بلده بيت لاهيا وايضا تخون
منطقه بيت حانون او غرب شمال بيت حانون
وبالتالي هذه المناطق كانت فيما سبق مسرحا
ايضا لسلسله من الغارات الاسرائيليه خلال
الساعه الماضيه الان تعود الطائرات
الحربيه الاسرائيليه وتغير على ثلاثه
اهداف يتصاعد منها السنه اللهب واعمده
الدخان والاتربه وهو كما يبدو في سياق
الغارات او سلسله الغارات الاخيره التي
شنتها طائرات اسرائيليه في مناطق متفرقه
من قطاع غزه لا سيما في منطقه محافظه
الشمال التي تضم منطقه بيت لاهيا وبيت
حانون وجباليا ايضا فضلا عن منطقه ج غرب
وجنوب مدينه غزه وصولا الى منطقه المنطقه
الشرقيه الجنوبيه لقطاع غزه وممثله في
منطقتي خان يونس ورفح هذه المناطق كانت
خلال الساعه الماضيه مسرحا لسلسله من
الغارات الحربيه الاسرائيليه وحسب
المعلومات المتوفره ومن
مشاهداتنا من هذا المكان المرتفع فان هذه
المناطق عاده ما تكون اقرب الى المناطق
الزراعيه والتي تحتوي على بعض البيوت لكن
جيش الاحتلال الاسرائيلي يتحدث عن
انها تحتوي على تحصينات للمقاومه
الفلسطينيه او مرابط لاطلاق الصواريخ او
مقدرات للمقاومه الفلسطينيه ولذلك عمد على
قصفها حتى قبل اطلاق اولى الرشقات
الصاروخيه من قطاع غزه الان يعود الى
تكثيف هذا القصف وتحديدا في هذه المنطقه
الشماليه لقطاع غزه
[موسيقى]
بالفعل من الانفجار في سماء او على تخوم
محافظات قطاع غزه وبالتالي يمكن ان تكون
بالفعل نجحت في اعتراض عدد من هذه القذائف
الصاروخيه التي اطلقت من قطاع غزه اذا نحن
في هذه الاونه نكون بالفعل قد دخلنا مرحله
جديده من مرحله التصعيد الحاليه على قطاع
غزه والتي ابتدات بما يتعلق باغتيال ثلاثه
من قاده سرايا القدس لكن على اي حال كانت
الاجواء قبيل هذه الغارات واضحه بانها اخذ
شيئا فشيئا بالتوتر وما التصريحات
الاسرائيليه والتهديدات اضافه الى
التعليمات التي اصدرتها الجبهه الداخليه
الاسرائيليه للاسرائيليين لا سيما في
مناطق الغلاف واضح بانها كانت تنوي تنفيذ
سلسله من الضربات بحق مواقع تتبع للمقاومه
الفلسطينيه في اماكن متفرقه ونحن كنا
بالفعل رصدنا هذه الغارات التي استهدفت
فعلا بعدد كبير من الصواريخ عددا من
المناطق والاراضي الزراعيه والمواقع
العسكريه التي تتبع لفصائل المقاومه
الفلسطينيه قبل ان تعمد
فصائل المقاومه او المقاومه الفلسطينيه في
على اطلاق ثلاث رشقات صاروخيه من قطاع